Good morning everyone.
I am alive.
I would like to say that technically I'm not late.
We made up looped three times, but we started the stream on time.
So technically, I arrived on time.
I can't help it.
I keep thinking, like, there's a day I will win the nap.
Gotcha.
I was like, oh, the bed looks so comfy, dog.
I'm like, oh, look at this bed.
It's so comfy.
hour nap that that won't hurt anybody but it does it hurts me hurts me so much i've waited a whole year for this thank you for the akasupa cranberry thank you thank you i really appreciate yes it's been a whole year i think i think it was a arkham asylum was the game I first series I did when I came back so um happy okay the anniversary might be a little late but happy anniversary welcome back Batman oh my god Batman
happy anniversary it's almost two years that's true that's true we're rounding up like a pussy
but it is good to be back in the batman series um i'm looking forward to it i heard arkham city was an improvement to arkham asylum um which is like you know it's it's something that um is very rare these days to have well not these days this game came out 10 years ago by the way um yes we're all getting older nothing stops the march of time but any Anyway,
but it's hard for the sequels to be better than the original because that's like the hardest thing a game do.
And it's even funnier when, um, uh, okay, but then I heard what was the third game?
The third game was also better.
It was also really, really good.
And then it all went downhill and we don't acknowledge anything else that happened to this franchise.
But anyway, uh, uh, Tracomation, thank you.
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Uh, where are you?
Thank you for the Magenta Super?
thank you thank you hi everybody hi dr nick um anyway anyway let's get started um also that update i talked about this in the member stream but um i got my very first noise complaint today i got really scared because i was like oh my god like it's because i stream sometimes i stream sometimes yes sometimes um just a little hobby that i do but like it's because like i get really loud during my stream but no it's because of dad um thank god because it wasn't me um i got really scared but at least it but i found that it wasn't me um but uh he just like basically he was barking a lot at 10 in the morning and um i try not to like enable him this by this enable his behavior by ignoring him.
You know?
So like, so he doesn't get his way.
So the concierge called me and was like, uh, uh, hello, uh, I'm calling you because then your neighbors are complaining about your dog barking really, really loud.
And obviously I lied in these types of situations.
And was like, oh, I'm so sorry.
I was asleep.
So like, he must have been trying to wake me up.
And I didn't know.
So, yeah, obviously I lied and said, I don't have a dog.
But unfortunately, she was apparently knocking at my door.
And dad was barking at the door while she was doing that.
So, unfortunately, I kept being like, what dog?
Instead, she'd be like, oh, there's a dog.
Oh, then she'll be like, oh my god, are we haunted?
A ghost dog, yeah.
And then the concierge will be like, oh my god, a ghost dog.
But yes, I got my very first noise complaint today.
So that's unfortunate because I said this on stream.
But like, you know, I did say I want to move soon, like sooner slash one day.
But I want to leave on my terms.
And so, so I don't want to get kicked out.
I'm trying to leave on my terms here.
So I'm, so I already, I got strike one.
So I'm a little worried now because like, because now my neighbors are finally complaining.
Yeah, I'm going to leave on dad's turn.
Anyway, other than that, I also have a little small announcement.
uh regarding some merch stuff um I know I saved I saved the file no I did not give me a sec I was told by my man reminded why so my manager to to talk about this um and I almost forgot because I was I was eeping but uh we are doing a I also I pinned the message too so you guys it's not really an announcement like I already sort of told you guys what it is but last call for wave one of the dokey blade merch yes that means uh you can still pre-order the dokey blade stuff um and it'll be we're doing a last call uh and it's gonna the pre-orders will close on wednesday so yes you want to get your stuff in time we'll uh make sure to pre-order it before wednesday and i pinned the link in chat i mean i can still i still copy and paste it give me a sec oh my god type doki blade when it's just bite ramen yeah so we're doing a final call for pre-order so make sure to grab yourself before it's gone gone all right hashtag add over so we're finally gonna go back to Batman Arkham City welcome back
Batman you guys hear about the what's called the absolute series from Batman and they made Joker like buff as fuck because they're like wow why does because like the whole thing about absolute Batman is that he too is also buff at buff as hell but so they're like what kind of villains with absolute batman fight if he is so fucking jacked up and because it's like you know if we fight regular joker um if he fights regular joker he can literally squish joker with his thumb so so they're like i don't know we know what to do we're gonna make joker a buff ass monster
So, we're going to make all the villains buff as hell if they're going to fight Batman.
Yeah, for those who know, absolute Batman is like a fucking rectangle.
I'll show you guys before I boot up the game.
Yes, I know a lot about DC, because I'm actually a DC fan girl.
Also, for those who are wondering why his fucking Batman logo looks stupid as fuck, I'll show you guys the context of like I'll show you guys the image and I'll explain the Lord yes I know my DC Lord I'm a DC gal even though I play Marvel Rivals um I always been DC first because I love their comics and the they're animated so this is absolute Batman um it's a new it's a new comic series that they're doing and apparently it's like um it's really really good um and his Batman logo you're like that fucking logo looks stupid as I I agree I do agree with you but there is so there is it is it's so like they gave us the reason but I still think it looks fucking stupid but it's based off his axe so it's Batman holding a giant fucking axe so and they're like I'm gonna put that logo and I'm gonna use that as my fucking logo so um they basically jacked up not just Batman but all his other villains because I guess that's the only way to make sense as to why he's fucking struggling against the
other villains like like they're like I guess that makes sense like we're like how the fuck is he losing to villains if he's like this jacked up so they jacked up all the other villains and shit so these are this is what they look like now so there's a demon joker uh big ah bane So even,
you know how Bain's whole thing is that he's fucking, you know, he's big as fuck and he's like, his entire body is filled with like, I don't know, like cocaine or some shit.
Like, his entire body is filled with like, you know, drugs and everything.
But now they gave him more drugs.
They gave him, basically, they gave him more drugs.
So like, he's even crazier now.
So, welcome to the Absolute series.
Yeah, yeah, so it's pain, but, like, bigger now.
Yeah, so, like, all the villains are just a lot bigger and scarier.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, Batman, you can graduate.
You don't need to fight them.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I kind of like that though So So that's the Absolute Batman series Okay also another comic that I recently finished reading I don't remember the Like some of you comic nerds can like Tell me the comic name But it was one where it's about like The zombie It's sort of like Marvel Like Marvel zombies But they had a similar premise in the DC It was so good I highly recommend checking it out Um,
it's the one where, uh, there's like a computer virus or something, um, in the DC universe, and, like, basically the entire world is infected.
Um, no, it's not, it's not the song, is it DC's the one where the entire world was infected by this computer virus that's causing people to kill each other.
And it's also, um, affecting, uh, yeah, it's the anti-life, it was regarded to the anti-life equation.
Is it DCs?
I highly recommend checking that series out.
It's so good.
I was like, I think I spent like the entire like, uh, entire day like reading through it.
I'm going to double check just to be sure.
Because like, I don't know, maybe you're lying.
Yeah, it's, it was like, um, um, it was like about the anti-life equation.
It was so interesting.
Basically, like, even the superheroes were infected.
as well and they were trying to I'm just gonna double check if this is the one I'm thinking of uh yeah it is it's so good it's actually I would um I would highly recommend checking it out because I normally don't like say a lot of praise about like certain comic series um yeah I mean I would say praise but I would not link it be like you should check it out or something like that um but like the DC comic series from DC is so fucking good because I literally spent the entire day um entire day just reading the entire series because uh um I was just I was just like hooked in because I was like oh my god what the fuck is gonna happen next yes I will say it's much better I it I didn't want I don't know I don't really know much about the Marvel zombies franchise but like I think it was definitely like it was a very good read um so bro like like like Bain's like chest like it feels like he has like two like John ass man boobs I'm sorry I just now process how fucking ridiculous this looks
absolute Batman is not rich however uh demon Joker thank you for the super chat monster thank you thank you um but stop thank you for the super chat thank you thank Thank you.
The Absolute Series has done crazy stuff.
Batman spat his teeth out and vomited some acid to try to escape imprisonment.
Also, that's Bane without Venom.
He gets bigger.
Okay.
I did not know that because I have not caught up with the Absolute Series.
I just know like little bits and pieces because people were like, holy fuck, because the Vintlands get like crazier and crazier.
So apparently, yeah.
Okay.
I didn't even know that I was Bane without his goddamn Venom.
percent venom um that's like crazy uh but yeah i didn't give him the super chat thank you thing oh he gets okay how big does he get absolute absolute bane like people were making fun of the absolute batman design but we were but then like they read the series and was like holy fuck wait this shit fucking slaps i still haven't read really read the absolute series because um I don't know I don't have an excuse it's just because I did it like because I don't know I can't get over his design so I guess I never try to I never try to read it I just couldn't get over his stupid ass logo but I understand the whole premise I just it's just a logo I have to get over that uh i just it's just holy shit holy shit all right guys you remember how we saw uh how we saw how buff batman was um yeah that doesn't matter i was like where's batman i was like oh shit i mean that's not that big and i see him holding batman and i was like oh shit Wait,
holy fuck, I was like, he's not that big, and then I turned over, I was like, wait, is that Batman over there?
Oh my god, Batman!
He's just the guy, too.
That's pain, bro, no way that's 50% pain.
There's no, God, I wish that was me.
Dr. Cranberry, I like how someone's, no, that's, someone's like, six foot versus five, 11.
absolutely okay absolute absolute killer croc um but i'm not gonna spoil the dc's department you guys gotta you guys gotta read it i don't want to spoil what what the fuck is absolute croc it's not even a fucking crocodile anymore
okay okay look at this look at this he's not even a crocodile anymore this guys these designs are fucking wild bro it's just what the fuck is just his mouth is his entire body um i know about the absolute joker because he we're like jesus christ uh joa thank you for the super chat thank you thank you absolute wonder woman is as proportionally buff as the men zero out of 10 thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um uh what Yeah,
what the fuck happened to him?
It's...
It's me.
What the fuck does he mean?
It's me, Bruce.
That's crazy.
Holy shit, he's just all mouth.
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Patman can even kill even if he wants to.
This feels like a targeted attack by Darkseid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I feel like maybe at this point he should kill.
holy shit this guy is fighting his fucking inner demons right now like and these demons are apparently real all right it's time to boot up the game i hope i have sound team online today um he gave it they gave him my axe and he can't even use it that's so fucking sad uh
all right let's boot up the game
cat woman if she's not as buff as the others there's no point like um writer thank you for the super chat thank you thank you did you see that halo 1 remake is coming to the ps5 when i already played the halo 1 i saw about it it was on my timeline everyone was talking about it and um but like i don't know i mean is it just halo 1 like what else did they remaster so the game is not popped there it is it took like 20 years for the game to pop up it's her dark wing dokey airborne ninja they give us super chat thank you thank you okay let me uh grab what is my resolution normally let me uh let me boot up the game real quick uh there you go okay uh make sure there's no motion blur no motion blur please you know how like when you know it's a really old game and um and they give you like a second thing to boot up where you have to play with the settings and stuff before you can actually boot up the real game that's what i'm fucking doing right now uh i have to do the they give you the second
mini menu all right here you go oh all right i need a tab out too because i the fuck is batman batman where the fuck is batman what the fuck i tab okay okay it's not showing that i'm a little concerned because i don't see it i i don't see it on the oh i'm a i'm very concerned i'm trying to see in my screen cap the the screen capture thing and i do not see it and i'm a little worried i'm i'm a little worried all right i might have to do like not game capture but the uh nvidia um the other one okay maybe i'll show up now i don't tell me it's some fucking stupid ass name that's not about batman it's still not up so i might have to do the other capture Wait,
it's not in any of this.
What the fuck, Batman?
Batman!
Hello!
Searching for download.
I might have to do, like...
Uh...
Oh my god, Batman.
I might have to do, like...
Um...
Uh, not full screen to see if it fucking detects it.
Okay.
Let me reboot the game.
Because my OBS is like, where's the game?
And I'm like, what do you mean where's the game?
It's right there.
I'm looking at it right now.
He's sneaking around somewhere.
Okay, let's escape.
Searching for...
Okay, if I click the save file, is it going to automatically...
Is it automatically going to play the game?
I hope not.
I can't close...
I can't force...
Okay, I don't know if I should force close the game.
Alright.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, shit.
This looks so weird.
All right.
Adjust gameplay.
There we go.
All right.
Never mind.
Uh, it seems to me that... Wait, no, I don't need to test the PC's benchmark.
I actually press test the PC's benchmark.
So it's running a benchmark test right now.
I... It's ready.
It's like these are the amount of frames you're gonna get.
I'm like, thank you.
All right, let's see if it shows up yet.
No, it still does.
doesn't show up.
That's so fucking weird.
Alright, I think I actually have to force quit this game.
Um...
Let me force quit it real quick.
Alright, goodbye, Batman.
I'm done playing with you.
Goodbye, Batman!
Alright, uh, Zan here.
Zan here, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello, Doki.
It is I, the Riddler.
I've hidden the answer to your tech issues in a hundred statues within ten miles.
of you.
All right, what's the cheat code?
I require the cheat code right now.
All right, let's see if I... I'll just do it.
Oh, fuck, I have to boot it.
Are you serious?
You gotta boot it up as...
Oh, my god.
Okay, never mind.
I gotta force quit Batman again.
All right, Batman.
Goodbye, Batman.
Yet again.
End task.
Because you're supposed to just click PC options.
All right.
configure PC options.
I gotta make it windowed or something.
So my fucking OBS detects it.
It is so annoying.
I hope it detects it.
Uh, okay.
Wait, maybe let's check.
It'll fucking recognize the Batman launcher, but it doesn't recognize Batman the game.
That's so stupid.
All right.
Don't tell me it has a weird ass name.
Oh my god, I swear.
i got it okay there you go i found it it's it exists i have to you can't it doesn't figure it doesn't like recognize the game when it's on full screen which is pretty stupid
all right let me i don't what's the full screen guys which one what's the full screen uh uh shortcut on the keyboard again story not started yeah no shit let's try Oh my god, are you kidding me?
Oh my god!
What is it not to take my controller?
Oh, okay.
Later.
We'll update our controller later.
Alright, do I have to play on PC?
Like, uh, controllers.
Is that the...
Oh my god, it's Xbox controllers.
Okay, give me...
Let me fucking get my Xbox controller.
Dad was like, what's that noise?
I'm like, sorry.
trying to grab my xbox controller it was i had my playstation controller it's just little things in life all right i got my xbox do you recognize it now there we go it's been recognized all right what's the shortcut to make it so that um uh to make it so that's full screen because i don't know if i can play play like actually full screen full screen with the um with the the pc options f11 alt enter i hope it's alt entry because i don't have 11 my keyboard oh my god that was all right here we go oh my god it made it worse give me all right let's see i got a plan guys guys i got a plan all right i'm gonna exit the game and yeah it made it worse okay i have a plan So now that my game has figured out where Batman is,
I should be able to play full screen now.
Guys, I have a plan.
Don't worry.
All right, settings.
Full screen.
Play.
Okay, now it should be in Shirley, right?
OBS?
Oh, there we go.
See, we fixed it.
There we go.
I'm so fucking smart.
We did it.
We did oh, that's all we had to do Nice In video All right, is any of my sound guy live like I asked that earlier and then I see saw no replies So like I'm a little worried All right riddler's revenge Character trophies Harley Quinn's revenge how how many people want to kill?
Okay, I'm Batman There's a lot of people that want to kill me.
All right, nice.
We have we have someone on live Alright.
Yes, hints.
Yes, absolutely.
We'll do...
We'll do normal.
I'm gonna make sure I tell... Because I don't...
Batman can't... Doesn't have a fucking gun.
So, like, we'll do normal.
Like...
If he had a gun, I'll play hard.
The least stressful night for Batman.
Batman.
What did you find?
Jesus Christ.
Subtitles for ants.
my back gun oh is this oh is this two-face is he here that my lawyer my bro
sorry to disappoint you whoa that's my girlfriend oh shit oh my god I get to play my girlfriend let's go sorry my on and off girlfriend the one i didn't have a child with bro i wonder if she's like jealous of what's her name how whatever her name is that like she ended up like uh getting a kid with batman nice i don't know if she's ever jealous of that talia yeah it's time to get what i came for out of that safe all right where is the save We don't talk about it.
I wonder if she's jealous about that.
I can't leave without cracking that safe.
What have I just...
Yeah, I was like, I just came here to beat the shit out of these guys and I leave.
Try and get one over on me, will you, Har?
I don't think so.
Oh, what the fuck kind of phone is this?
That's a giant ass SIM card.
Huh?
Get your filthy paws off that now.
Ah!
Wake up, Mr. Wake.
We have much to discuss.
You won't get away with this.
I already have.
This is Vicky Vale reporting live from Arkham City, the controversial super prison built right here in the heart of Gotham.
In a few moments, Bruce Wayne will be live on stage to explain his sudden interest in Gotham politics.
The infamous Playboy millionaire has never been one to...
Oh, that aged really poorly.
That aged really poorly.
What do you mean a billionaire shouldn't be interested in politics, guys?
I assume that you thought yourself untouchable.
No one is untouchable.
Thank you!
Thank you, Gotham.
In prison behind these walls.
Gang leaders are fighting a bloody war in the middle of our once great city.
Wait, did he build Arkham City?
There's no...
Yeah, I was gonna say, that's fucking stupid.
I guess you're like, you can't be crime if they all live in Arkham City.
It's out of control.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, he's trying to shut it down.
Okay.
Who the fuck made that decision to build Arkham City?
That's such a crazy idea.
Like, as if that would fucking solve the crime, right?
It's like creating Crime City.
He's like, don't wonder he wants to shut it down.
They were recreating Crime Alley.
Alright.
Arkham did so much easier than bad man you uh call 10 it's ready to begin it will be my legacy a monument to your failure and if you try to stop me I guarantee everyone will know your secret damn why don't you just expose me right now don't have to like tease him
James, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fun fact, at the point in time, Mark Hamill only played a Joker if Kevin Conroy was playing Batman.
After he died, he swore off of playing Joker, saying without...
Batman crime has no punchline.
Yeah, I knew about.
Yeah, oh yeah, I knew about that.
It's really sweet, you know, that, like, he'll only do Joker if it's with Kevin.
Because, like, they both started out together.
there.
Oh shit.
Damn.
Am I supposed to?
There's no way this is scripted.
Yeah.
Oh shit.
On the ground.
Can I just walk away?
Oh yeah, I do.
I have to line up.
Oh, this is Arkham.
Oh, I'm in Arkham City.
Where do I line up?
Yeah?
Oh, this is Line.
Oh, this is literally like Arkham Asylum.
Move away!
I'm the rich!
Oh, shit.
This guy is so fucking cocky.
Okay, bring overall and bring sound effects and music down.
Okay.
Let's listen to this part first.
Ooh.
Pinky.
All right, let's adjust the audio real quick.
All right, what was it?
Sound effects and music.
Ooh, that scientist is a freak.
It's like the handcuff stays on.
Wow, we.
Bro, take Bruce out for dinner first.
Wait, I was supposed to look up?
What was up above me?
Whoops, too late.
Don't forget to look up.
Too late.
They closed the door, guys.
Oh, not yet, okay.
When they open the door, do not panic.
Stay close to me.
Do you think I'm taking advice from some guy Oh, they don't know.
They're trying to scare us.
Is it this?
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Oh, yeah, no, he's dead.
They can spell weakness.
To be fair, they do look like nerds.
Oh, hey, there's Wayne.
There's Wayne Corp right there.
Yeah, that's fucking Wayne.
right that's fucking right you should have listened to me i you should fucking listen to me i said calm down and let me handle this now look at you and then you were like oh i'm not taking advice from a guy who can't fight yeah look who's on the ground right now on your feet rider help him you're fat man help him i said get up oh wait who's that on the roof?
Wait, who the fuck is that?
Oh, shit.
Oh, there's Penguin.
Yeah, Batman will save him.
I'm Bruce Wayne.
What are you talking about?
There's no reason for me to save him.
Oh, what's up?
Do you need me to call you, Butler?
Hello, Cobbapot.
Hello, Penguin.
Oh,
shit.
Okay, I can counter it.
That's looking right.
Broke your arm.
Okay, they stopped giving me prompts.
They're like, you don't need that anymore.
You're Bruce Wayne now
Oh shit How did yeah, how did he do that?
I thought he was just rich I thought the muscles was just ascetic or some shit Doesn't make shit sense Nice
He's a man?
You mean that six packs real?
I thought it was just...
Oh my god, you know how you can get plastic surgery where they like...
Um...
Okay, I gotta bring up the overall volume.
You can get plastic surgery where you can have fake abs basically.
I don't know exactly what they do, but they insert something in your...
on your torso that makes it look like you have abs, but they're not real.
Like...
It's fucking wild.
I saw like pictures of that shit.
Yeah, six-pack implants.
Yeah, it's a thing.
Yeah, oh, is it saltwater?
Yeah, you can literally have six-pack implants and stuff.
Need to get to higher ground and contact Alfred.
Alright, hold and run.
Okay, hold.
Sorry, that wasn't running.
Oh, and climb.
Okay, I gotta climb.
Sorry.
That was definitely a misinput, guys.
an accident.
Oh, there's a ladder.
Fair.
Guys, yes, it was definitely an accident.
I didn't mean to do that.
I'll just try to figure out how to run, Penguin.
And not my fault.
A billion beats up a cripple.
Um, crippled a billionaire.
So it was technically a fair fight.
It was the rich beating up the rich.
I needed immediate drop on the roof of the Ace Chemicals building.
I'm on my way there now.
Of course.
It's a rich on rich violence.
Exactly.
Oh shit.
I love the aesthetic of this.
Oh my god, it's the Bank of Gotham.
I, do you see that?
I own that.
You're under close surveillance.
Okay.
That, where else are I supposed to go?
Where am I supposed to go?
I just dropped down?
I can just about make that jump to the Oh, okay.
I'll be able to climb up from there.
This building?
Okay.
Okay, I was gonna say I don't know if I'll actually make that jump anymore.
It's a little hard to figure out like where to go next.
I need my yellow paint.
He knows that Bruce Wayne is Batman.
He also told me that something called Protocol 10 will make him famous.
I can't leave Arkham City until I find out what it is.
What the fuck is Protocol 10?
I guess we're finding that out soon.
Sometimes it makes it look like I am.
Oh, there's the Riddler trophies.
But sometimes it makes it look like I'm not going to grab the ledge.
It's a little scary.
I see it.
Look at all those riddler shit That we're never gonna get
But um But um But um But um But um Hello I'm at the top Oh this It looked like part of the building Gotta suit up I like walked past it I don't know Everything is Everything is black So like It just looked like part of the building Oh my god, it's rough,
man.
Shin, thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I wonder if you could just play the entire game as Bruce Wayne.
I'm hacking.
Access broadcast key.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, the mayor is corrupt!
Sorry, sorry, sorry, Alfred, I'm listening to the radio right now.
I'm listening to the news!
Okay, what about this, China?
Oh, shit.
A corrupt mayor?
No way, in Gotham City?
A corruption in Gotham City?
Not my city.
into the soup for all i can all right i should start hacking now get decode oh
cat woman that's my girlfriend
that doesn't sound good
yeah if there's one person in arkham city she's too symmetrical what is she trying to steal anyway cat woman now all right hold off the edge hold to
I'm Batman.
Okay, we gotta go here.
Let me save Catwoman.
Do I have...
Okay, so that makes it...
Alright, we gotta go this way.
Oh, run to glide.
Oh, this is like open world.
That's cool.
We're not like confined to like a place now.
Wait, what is that?
Is this...
Oh, is this goddamn Riddler shit?
Yeah, it is.
What?
What is this?
Zero, what?
Oh!
Over here!
Okay.
Yeah, it's the Riddler's trophy.
I'm gonna get it.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I was...
like figuring out how to get it.
Alright.
I'm gonna get it.
Alright, nice.
First trophy.
Yeah, yeah.
First try.
Please, I spent $1 million doing these riddles.
He's like, Batman, please.
I invested a million dollars into all these riddles.
You gotta do it.
Really a professional criminal.
Gotham City.
Oh shit, he's six foot- he's six foot one.
Whimp session compulsive need for attention.
Is there room to be the cleverest of Gotham City's criminals?
Alright.
Don't let him start tossing that coin.
I'm really glad kick.
Wee!
The slowest fucking attack of his life.
How the fuck did he get hit by that?
He's literally telegraphing that 20 miles away.
Alright, got your foot.
Oh, combat's pretty easy, though, which is nice.
Time to get our kicks in.
Oh my god.
Okay, combat is easy, but they are all like goddamn sponges.
However, I feel like I'm doing nothing.
like I'm hitting, like, a punching bag.
Boom!
My nuclear fist!
There you go.
Okay.
Oh, he's still alive.
Get out of here.
Batman's gonna give you a concussion because Batman don't kill.
I would love to play an absolute Batman game, though.
I won't fucking swing that axe.
Don't worry, it gets hardy.
I did not mean to what... I didn't say I wanted to get hardy.
All right, let's go through the normal door.
Just hospitalized.
All right.
I don't think I have gadgets yet.
The tutorial, the hints didn't tell me about any gadgets.
Hello.
Oh, knock, knock.
I'm too late.
Oh my god, wait, is this a courtroom?
Oh my god.
Are we going to trial Catwoman?
The law of...
Oh my god, wait, we are!
Oh wait, I don't think there is a trial.
We want you.
The only way to get by in this place is to get ourselves some respect.
Be here.
That's how we get respect.
Show them all that we do things.
We should be fair, though.
This is a place of justice.
Yeah, I was going to say, this is a court in session?
Killer, and they'll all fear us.
you know what i'm impressed by with two-faced how he doesn't get any like infections on the half of his body
oh that's we're stealing from us no one steals from us i'm sorry i've been a bad kitty whoa me yeah Let's see if the coin...
Absolutely.
Meow.
This court is now in session.
Oh shit, he gets... he won.
He gets to be a lawyer again.
Alright, Harvey Dent, professional criminal.
District Attorney was one of Batman's strongest allies in Gotham City.
I knew that.
He went through acid and dense veins, hiddlingly scarring him.
The wounds fractured his psyche, and he was reborn to face a schizo-criminal mastermind obsessed with duality.
His former good luck charm, a two-headed trick silver dollar, was damaged on one side of the attack, and Dent has seized on it as a reflection of his half-scared visage.
All right.
You know what I did like from the Harley Quinn show?
I liked his D.I.
that each villain is like a crime lord in like each parts, like in different parts of Gothen City.
I like that premise for Gothen City that they're all like a crime lord in each district and stuff.
Instead of just being like anarchy, like and it's, oh does Arkham City do that too?
That's inspired.
Oh, is it that's basically, oh is it Oh, that's cool.
I actually really like that premise.
Um, I like that.
So, like, instead of, like, the, uh, the Gotham criminals running anarchy on, like, everywhere.
Like, they have, like, a special district and shit.
That's cool.
I like that.
I've always liked that premise.
That's why I like the Harley Quinn show.
The first season?
But then, like, then the- Taking out the thug with the gun is the key.
But then the other season got really bad.
All right, get it out of here.
Batman, no need guns.
but I have this
I thought it would just be like mission spelled oops
Okay, okay, I have a perfectly good reason why I thought it would be funny.
Sarah, I thought it'd be funny.
I legitimately thought that I would, um, it would be like mission failed.
I had to redo it again.
I didn't realize I just landed right into them.
Give me a sec.
Oh, shit.
Oh, what the fuck did I do?
All right.
objection oh shit overruled that's not fair he had a gun I was using my fist heads or tails kitty cat what happens if I didn't just fall down not this one oh time to die I vote for a stay of execution ah ah uh Overrule.
This is gonna hurt.
Two guns, bitch.
Whoa, two guns?
Oh, it pre-brought two guns into the court?
I thought it was cats who have nine lives.
One for each face.
That's cheating.
How's it hanging, Harv?
Oh.
Oh no.
Don't go back to my place later.
So what do you need, Mr. Detective?
Protocol 10.
What do you know, Selena?
Never heard of it.
That's not what I wanted to hear.
What about strange?
I don't trust him.
He's been missing for years.
And then is suddenly put in charge of running Arkham City.
Rumor has it he's been working with Joker.
Planning something very special just for you.
Maybe that's protocol 10.
Twinkle, twinkle little bat.
Watch me kill your favorite cat.
Joker?
the little smiley face that's so cute other than the fact that it that it was a sniper shot that's actually a really nice touch this place is dangerous i like it you expecting a kiss it was joker you're not safe here bro take the bait but she's giving that for free she's
it locate where the bullet entered the court and where it impacted okay so what would have happened if i didn't just fall down i'm actually curious all right oh evidence scanner oh here you go i'll scan this evidence the bullet entered through the window there now where did it hit oh that was what i was actually supposed to wait where did it it hit okay so with physics wise it should go like somewhere here shouldn't it
what oh wait there it is oh my god so tiny i'm Sherlock Holmes in here right now the bullet traveled will lead me to the shooter
I'm look using my figs like spring
all right the joker oh i just don't know what he looks like oh my god my my arch nemesis what the fuck does he look like again like that's so sad sorry like batman has early onset dementia apparently has no superpowers beyond a capacity for incredible violence and a skill at creating deadly uh mayhem since his last encounter a dark night the joker has been transferred to arkham city.
All right.
Bad memory.
I'm like, how do I not remember how the Joker looks like?
Okay, I'm going to talk to you.
You should have finished me, Batman.
We'll get out of this and we'll be back.
Do I look scared, Harvey?
You should.
Fate is all that stands in our way.
And if the coin says that your time is up, then you'll me we don't get you joker with it
oh imagine i just accidentally accidentally killed harvey just be like oopsie
that'll be pretty wild the un yeah that's why it was an accident but never kills.
It was just a little oopsie.
The basement.
Oh my god, Calendar Man!
The new June and September of 28 is but one.
All the rest are 31.
Batman is like such a silly supervillain.
Every four years got it right.
And 28 is 29.
Batman doesn't kill, but gravity does.
That's true.
I love Calendar Man.
Don't be scared, Batman.
Halloween will be a day to celebrate if you come and see me.
Wait, is this game based?
Wait, is it Halloween?
Halloween, Halloween.
All Saints Day.
Wake up the witches or someone will pay.
Wait, oh, I didn't even realize.
That wasn't even a reason why I picked this game.
Wait.
Oh, it's based on the date?
Oh, wait, no, oh, because it's almost Halloween for me.
He's talking about Halloween.
The perfect timing.
Oh, that's cool.
That's so cool.
Wait, how do I get the real-earth jokes here?
That's cool.
I like that.
I thought he actually, like, syncs up to your calendar for Calendar Man.
Calendar Man.
I forgot, like, his entire lore.
I just thought he's so silly.
Like, his entire...
Like, he just...
He just really loves the fucking calendar.
Detective mode?
Oh, there's something here.
Yeah, he kills based off of...
Oh, yeah, he kills based off of holidays.
I remember it now.
Alright.
Wait, do I just...
Oops.
Alright.
maybe what wait did i do it no there's no way yeah i didn't do it oh do i have the remote battery i don't do i have it oh i do have it wait no i don't backlog explosive gel yeah i can't yeah i don't have it
i guess i leave Wait, down right?
Oh, do I have to do down right?
Oh, I thought it was, like, locked or some shit.
Okay, wait.
Okay, give me a sec.
They didn't give me a tutorial on this, so I'm, like, just as confused.
Fucking hell, okay.
Wait, I can break it?
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I'll figure this out.
Okay, slower.
Alright, there we go.
Oh, yeah.
Don't let me control a drone.
Alright, there you go.
That should hit it.
Did I do it?
Wait.
That...
Wait a minute.
What did I do?
Okay.
Did it not?
I need the electric bat!
Oh my god.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
I need an electric bat around.
It needs to pass electric...
Wait.
Is there electricity here?
There has to be electricity around here.
I heard...
There it is.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my...
Okay, this better...
oh my god oh okay what if i shoot it from here okay jesus christ so stupid this actually oh my god here we go
Okay, we can do this.
We're almost there.
No!
Okay, this is a fucking stupid puzzle.
I hope the Riddler's investment was worth...
No, it was definitely worth it for him.
The Riddler is having the time of his life right now, watching from his fucking phone.
There we go.
we did it all right i don't i bet the riddler has like fucking cameras all over here watching from his little phone all right nice i got your stupid ass trophy oh
it doesn't he doesn't talk to me i just gotta find it i wouldn't anyone do this to themselves
I got caught.
Oh, that's why.
Guys, I got caught some art of calendar math.
It was so worth it.
Yeah, he's iPad kidding right now.
I don't think they hurt us.
Good.
I can't believe we're still out here at night.
Uh-huh.
I told you I was sorry.
I lost track.
Let's hope it doesn't get us killed.
You just need to be careful.
Oh, there they are.
I move when they fight.
They'll be too busy killing each other to notice us heading back to the camp.
I don't understand why they for this place.
Two-face ends up owning that bit of street.
So what?
He's still stuck in here.
Do you think they see me?
Wait, which one was the map?
Oh, shit.
Uh, okay, it's less.
Uh, I have to go this way.
Oh, my God.
This is a big-ass map now that I look at it.
Okay.
Hello, guys.
Hello, fellow politicians.
You're the last person I expected to see in here.
What did you do?
I'm Batman.
Who are you?
Who was I, you mean?
In here, you're nothing.
Out there?
I worked at the company.
Have you ever thought about leaving?
Yeah, me too.
Don't tell me.
You were sent here by Strange.
Wait, Crime Alley is an art... Crime City?
You obviously know something you shouldn't.
Try to figure out what that is and stay out of sight.
Oh.
That was an accident.
You're still in there?
I think so.
I can hear someone in there.
Keep that door shut, man.
I don't want to go head-to-head with Batman.
You didn't say it was Batman.
Why the hell are we still here?
We should run or something.
Oh, that's cute.
Don't be stupid.
If you keep that door closed, he can't get out, and we are safe.
Really?
What's stopping him going out the back?
Yeah, I was going to say.
There's a back?
There's a basement.
It's full of cells.
There's some guy there.
There's a back door?
Oh.
Hey guys.
What are you guys waiting for?
That's a little awkward.
Boop.
That's pretty awkward, isn't it guys?
There's a back?
Yep.
A back for Batman.
A little awkward, isn't it?
Feel a little bit stupid now.
That's right.
He punched my nuclear fist.
Jesus Christ, look, you know I'm breaking some bones right now.
I'm fucking taking these guys.
Maybe that's how Arkham funds their city.
It's literally just hospital bills.
You combo?
There's combos?
Alright, nice.
Goodbye, guys.
Now I'm just gonna aura walk to my next destination.
I was a maniac, but Penguin is worse.
Where is that?
Let's just aura walk over.
He's young, exactly.
He'll walk again.
Oh, I should be able to go...
Okay, no, that's steam.
I mean, I should be able to do this, right?
Oh, never mind.
Tap left trigger for a quick batter at?
Oh, that's what it is.
That's what it is.
I bet she's nice and warm in there.
Take it easy, man.
I'm just asking.
Who was that lady?
The one who got dragged off.
No idea.
It took a lady?
I hope the Joker hurts her bad.
Ozari will.
He ain't been his usual happy self for a while now.
No!
You think the Romans are true?
He wasn't happy?
Whoa!
about the Joker dying.
No idea, man, but he didn't look too good last time I saw him.
No, I know this.
Oh, guys.
Okay, it's not spoilers because I remember this plot twist.
Like, the Joker got the Joker got, like, cancer or something.
I forgot about that.
It's like in the third game, um, in the third game, he's, like, dead.
Uh, and and like, and like, he just hallucinates the Joker.
He got super cancer.
Alright.
What did I do?
Wait, what?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, it's the explosive gel.
Wait, how do I get that to work?
Random bullshit, go!
I'm at the church.
It looks like Harley Quinn is inside.
Oh, is that Harley Quinn?
There's no doubt setting a trap for you.
Alfred Quinn never was too smart.
I'll be okay All right, geez, what do you mean Harley Quinn?
She hasn't she has a master's degree.
What the she she has a doctorate Harley Quinn was never that's when damn Batman Damn, sorry.
I'm sorry if I spoiled it for you guys I just remember that scene because it was so famous on my Yeah, she literally has a fucking PhD of Batman man jesus uh titan's overdose in arkham asylum how is mine's further deteriorated she's finally determined to put a smile back on this yeah because he overdosed on titan so now he got like i guess super cancer now um that's why they couldn't like make more arc like batman games like they couldn't really make more sequels to the backman arkham series because you know they
So it's not the same.
That's what I remember.
They're like, well, he's dead.
What do we do now?
You can't flip forever.
You can't flip forever, Harley.
That's right.
Okay, there we go.
We did it.
Wait, I just hit her once.
smack
I didn't think she did just takes one stab yeah so anyway here's the deal Mr. J is really not up to a visit right now he's not feeling himself well actually he was earlier but that's not what I meant he's not doing so good in that idiot doctor I sent from here I've seen more smarts from these bozos.
I've got to run, boys.
If he tries anything funny, kill him.
Oh, geez.
Bro, what?
You lost the fight.
What?
Attacking armed thugs head-on is suicide.
I need to disappear.
Pick them off silently one by one.
Well, they sort of know I'm here now.
Oh, shit.
What do you mean?
Pakistan!
Where could I go?
Gamers don't look up.
Time to survey the room.
Plan out my tactics.
Alright.
Four thugs, all armed, two hostages.
This is gonna be easy.
Oh shit.
Is this though?
Black man.
Can you hear me?
Try and get us beneath.
That won't stop him.
Oh man, I'm gonna die in here.
Alright.
R-T-Y.
Okay.
Wait, am I not?
Oh, I am.
Okay.
Oh, wait, I'm not...
Am I?
Okay, wait, we gotta go here.
I'm thinking, guys.
He thinks he's safe in the confessional.
He's just made it easier for me to get in behind him.
Wait, he did?
He...
He did?
I was like, really?
Batman, you gotta tell me what to do, Batman.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Okay.
If I can get behind those two without being seen, I can take them both in one move.
I can?
Bro, he's like saying things.
Um.
Oh,
double takedown.
Okay, there you go.
There we go.
Nice.
And then we go back up.
You're safe now.
Batman's here.
Where is he in the confession of?
Oh, I have to go this way.
Okay.
Oh, when by wooden panel?
Holy shit!
Oh my god, that's crazy.
That's crazy.
Wait here and don't make a noise.
Let's see, look.
Human organs.
Wait, I need that.
Oh, there's one more.
Okay, I'll do that too.
I got you.
He's got a hostage.
I can glide to the scaffolding above him without being seen.
And take him down from there.
Holy shit, these are all like the self shit.
Weeeeee.
Silent takedown went directly above them.
Am I not above?
Oh, here we go.
Oh, that's cool.
I'm gonna forget all of this.
Oh my god, my thighs.
My thighs are still got him.
The room is secure.
You're safe now, everyone.
My back thighs secured it.
Yo, Batman.
Thanks for the help.
i leveled up what do i get select your upgrade from the wane tech selection oh i like that wait what okay guys what is the best upgrade to get chat what is the best one i'm level two batman now batman that saves lives it's confirmed batman sexist simple-minded thank you for the super chat Thank you.
Alright, which one?
Gadgets in combat?
I don't think I...
Can I even do gadgets in combat?
I don't think I can.
Yeah.
Wait, oh wait, no, I can.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
What do I...
What's the best...
Oh my god, there's so many upgrades.
Holy shit.
Wait, what do I get?
Predator.
Whoa!
Oh, okay, it's just a takedown.
That was like...
man what oh there's like cat woman okay how many times will you even fight with cat woman though shockwave or shockwave critical strike event critical strike where is that oh this one is this one we get that
strike just after finishing previous okay all right great for early game oh grab that then all right this will display on screen but impromptu required a poor farm all right nice i need that actually i will upgrade that yeah i saved them i'm a hero all
right new gadget available now
well later we're definitely not in control earlier oh hey there's the organ donor what happened Yeah.
He's not a prisoner.
He's a doctor.
Was he attacked?
No.
It's terrible, really.
He transferred here, but I think it was too much for him.
We didn't realize he was losing it.
And he, we should have noticed.
Noticed what?
Notice what?
Oh.
What?
I used them when he...
When he cut his own face.
What?
I found him.
He was sitting in the corner, laughing.
His face.
He got jokered!
I knocked him up and sedated him.
Who knows what's in that case he's holding on to.
We couldn't try it loose.
I mean, it says human organs.
Oh my god.
Locate the location.
How crazy do you have to be to cut your own face off?
Yeah, I was gonna say, Jesus.
I wonder, like...
Did he got jokered or some shit?
Talk to the doctor.
Wait, there's doctors?
Hello.
that woman come in here and do all this why kill us quinn's only priority is to protect joker she's dangerous so i see well thanks batman it's funny i figured people would be grateful to have us here i guess i was wrong yeah that was your first why the fuck would you go to crime city that's where crime is these animals will pay
I mean, yeah, I felt like the prison system was a lot, should be a bit, like, was a lot better.
Thank God you got here, Batman.
After what happened at the asylum, I thought you'd settle for a quiet desk job.
Yeah, right.
When Shark closed down the asylum, it turned out there wasn't much work for an ex-security guard who failed to stop a mass breakout.
That's true.
That doesn't look good on the resume.
here that crazy bitch busted in a couple of hours ago with the rest of these idiots took something up the tower then blew up the staircase thanks I'll check it out all right why would they do that sorry Batman I forgot a couple of them grabbed one of the docks Quinn said something about needing her to fix up the Joker if she's alive I'll find her you concentrate on securing this church oh so they have hostages again hope you find the doc her name's Stacy Baker she's one of the good ones you mean they're a battle oh yeah yeah there's yeah i forgot there are a lot of bad ones the asylum i volunteered to work in cash's crew figured we could make a difference
okay uh interrogate locate the source of the sniper shot i assume it's up top wasn't it
why is this highlighted I'll use my detector.
Oh, there.
I need to find a way up there.
Yeah, I was going to say it.
I just need to figure out how to get up there.
Can we broken with enough force?
Wait.
Oops.
I guess I'll open this door.
Alright, I'm up here now.
Is the bell tower?
I assume it is.
There's bells here.
I mean, it makes sense.
Okay.
Oh, grappling.
It's like there's like a lot of places you can explore with all the tools you have.
There's the gun.
Oh.
It looks like it's being controlled remotely by Joker.
Yeah, we got to scan this evidence area.
Let's scan this gun.
Oh, there he is.
Hello, Joker.
I haven't seen you for...
How long has it been?
Let's see.
There was an asylum, some monsters, and all that's right.
You left me to die.
Now you probably don't...
You try to kill me!
You just need to worry about the bombs.
The bombs?
Hurry up now.
Clock's ticking.
No way I'm timed, right?
Oh, shit, I'm timed!
Oh, shit!
Let it fit.
Okay, all right, we made it.
Was there ever any doubt?
The radio signal should lead me right to it.
Good luck, sir.
Track down the source of the signal to locate Joker.
Well, yeah, okay, guys, I will say, like...
Look, all I'm saying, like...
Look, all I'm saying, like, why would my first instinct be, you know, to go to the...
Go to where the bomb, like, say where the bomb was.
We're safer here than out there.
I'll get us some food.
Yeah, I would have not known that.
It's literally like...
No, I shouldn't.
I know they're just standing there menacingly.
It's this way.
Wee!
That's this.
No way.
Must have been something to do with Holly.
I told you she was up to something earlier.
Why would Joker want the roof of a church blow?
That's this.
Oh my god, it's a stupid riddle shit.
His million dollar investment on just to fucking piss me off.
Wait, crime alley?
Is this crime alley right here?
Yeah, keep up, man.
What the fuck is crime alley?
That's a wall, yeah.
Oh, not yet?
Okay, I was gonna say, where can I give him trauma?
Wait, why are there balloons?
Wait, there's balloons there.
Oh, shit!
Yeah, I can keep going up.
What's this?
What is that open?
Oh, here.
Okay, I'm not bothering with that.
Wait, not here?
Come on, man.
I'm starving here.
Just give me a couple of minutes.
You ever stop to take what's in those cans?
I'm just listening to these criminals having their most casual conversations.
Welcome, inmates.
You are now taking your- Why are the balloons here?
Yay!
Wait, Jokerland?
Oh my god, Funland!
It has to be here.
That's where all the fun go begins what's the policy today where it is we shoot every sorry ass loser that comes this way okay yay fun land that's where you have fun boom boom boom boom run a bullshit let's go boom boom boom but okay let's just boom boom just stop just keep Fucking throwing my stupid ass batter heads.
Batter!
Random bullshit!
Go!
Bad haunts you.
Sorry.
Wrong.
Wrong company.
There you go.
I just keep slapping.
Random bullshit.
Yay!
Nice, we did it.
I want to activate my trap here, anyway.
Alright.
Oops.
Okay, there's people over here.
Alright, is this...
No, it's not this way.
Is it this way?
Okay, it's this way.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
It's me, Batman!
By the time, they can't even get to me.
That's how fucked up it is.
I could just keep throwing this.
I have unlimited Batarans.
70% of the Batman budget goes to Batarans.
Let's go.
I got my deep ass.
Wait, how did he get here?
He was not supposed to...
to be my fatter hands are supposed to avoid that there you go okay fine I'll watch your stupid ass AR training all right there you are you happy now game money well spent let's go
huh I know what you guys are thinking is it all true is life with.
I'm listening.
Mr. J is...
but look on the bright side.
At least you know what you're getting yourself into.
Listen up, Don Agnes.
And listen carefully.
I'm listening.
You know...
Mr. J is...
He's...
He's not himself.
And the last thing he needs is any so-called superhero coming in here and stopping his recuperation.
That's where you come in, morons.
You need to protect the steel mill.
Protect it with your life.
Oh, there it is.
Because if you fail, I'll make sure your lives don't make zips.
Hello?
Oh, security area.
Alright, that's fine.
I can do that.
Slap.
Oh, there we go.
I have to time it correctly.
Okay, let me see.
I can time this.
I'm trying to get the critical strike thing working.
Oh, shit!
I got it!
Boom!
Alright.
It's random bullshit time.
I'm done.
I can't shoot a gun, but I can shoot battle.
friends.
There you go.
Get out of here.
I like how even the Bataran does like a fucking nuke sound effects too.
All right, let's answer the phone.
Hello, Batman.
Do you recognize my voice?
Zaz?
Victor Zaz.
In the flesh.
I'm so happy you remember me.
I'll never forget.
you i've got a special game planned batman a game just for you really is that where all the budget goes they just want to make some fun games for me all right oh it's him shadow of the bat none formally blind
a true sociopath zaz grew up in the life of ease but nonetheless became a serial killer in the in his prey body count is the only thing that matters um he craves cars a mark for each of the victim um into his own body and saving a special spot for batman wait where would i where would i go where would i have the special spot be i'm a little worried where do you think the special spot is his special spot Arkham City is the home to the most notorious criminals.
Okay, so I assume like that's the AR training.
Oh, that's cool.
They have like radio signals.
That's cool.
Wait, but where would Zaz be?
I guess we'll never know what Zaz's special game is.
Sorry about the Joker having super cancer he gets five big booms uh season thank you the super chat thank you thank you oh is it random phone calls oh i see
yeah that's right i'm using it right now
we're gonna go to a little fun house oh
Wait, is it not here?
I don't want to get rid of the local surveillance.
I don't want to hear them.
Like, I don't like the overlap dialogue that it does.
Oh, is it up?
Oh, it's always on.
I feel like the local surveillance should, like, Turned off when, you know, the Joker is talking.
I don't know.
Maybe that makes too much sense.
Alfred, I need to find a route into the Cyanus steel mill.
Have you tried the front door, sir?
Why didn't I think of that?
It was
obviously...
I see where I am.
The main chimney.
Okay, then.
The chimney?
Oh, it's like literally next to me.
Yeah, it's that.
Oh my god, look, that's... Okay, yeah, no wonder... Okay, Batman.
That's looking crazy, but what if...
No, Doki, don't give in to your intrusive... Okay, but what happens?
Stupid little dead bat!
Who's gonna save you now?
Okay.
No, I didn't deserve that.
Stupid little bitch.
Alright.
I was just curious.
I was like, do I get...
Like, he doesn't even say anything.
He just accepts it.
Like, that's crazy.
I think it's crazy that he just accepts his spate.
He's like, he doesn't say any...
No, not even a scream.
He just fucking disappears into...
With the lava.
He's cool.
That's why.
Hmm.
I thought it was just crazy that he doesn't even bother to say anything.
Okay.
Nice.
That's cool.
Of all the different gadgets.
I assume I had to drop down.
Because I cooled it.
Getting from the end.
Oops.
Oop.
Owey.
Okay.
Go here.
Ah.
Zoom is here.
Alright.
Detective mode.
Oh, right here.
Okay.
Oh my god, it's my explosive gel.
Where I get to draw my little pictures too.
There you go.
Put it back on the batter end.
There's so many controls to remember.
Ow.
Oh, there's a button here.
There you go.
Yeah, Joker wants you to think you're sick.
I don't know, man.
I promised you some entertainment, right, boy?
Yeah?
Wait, that's a doctor!
No!
Bro, okay, she could have...
Okay, honestly, she would have been dead by now here.
Am I supposed to just watch?
Mr. Hammer?
Holy shit!
Oh my god, wait, how do I save it?
Oh,
that's awkward.
Oh, give me a sec.
I'm going to try and figure this out.
Don't worry, I'll save you very soon.
It's very nice of them to wait for me.
Oh, is it time?
Oh, it is.
Okay.
I thought I'd feel like it was it took so long
Hammer hammer Look at the please give me five seconds.
I'm a little lost
I think I waited a little too long
You know what you've got to do go get the snowman he's gonna pay for screwing over mr jay i need him back here like
yeah all right let's go this way okay at least like it's scripted you know at least like i was wondering like if i wait too long to save her do they just like take her away the steam is blocking the exit if i follow the pipe back i may find a way to joker really must be sick after all i guess oh i keep accidentally going to there you just quick guys hammer hammer hammer hammer
all right yeah normal like he ever looks normal okay whatever he looked like the joker just takes down time that's right veteran veteran veteran oh oh my god he had a box you see that wait does he just throw a box at me if i don't kill him okay they're just medicine walking over with that box thank god my punches have aim bot no i have aim assist on my punch my kicks and everything thank god That's so convenient.
There we go.
That's where I have aim assist.
My one tap.
Bro, I'm like literally one HP right now.
I need to make sure I don't get hit.
Alright, nice.
doing here you're supposed to be well there's no way you're getting to mr jay we're safe and sound up here you can just stay down there and burn burn what does she mean by that oh nice level up all right what should we get next chat what do we get next we get bataran i feel like bataran might be a like not upgrade oh wait i can't that's literally it's like back clawed what's but back clawed this arm nah i don't know armor oh yeah i should ballistic armor or combat armor wait which do we get health i assume it's the there's no health upgrade though so i assume it's
combat armor all right we'll do combat
armor is shit okay well too late you should have said that oh now you tell me armor is shit jokers hold up in the manager's office in the steel mill i'm sure you'll find a way sir of course i will i just not call robin where the fuck is robin what's the point of recruiting all these robins if they don't like kill for him i mean sorry well red hood technically is the one that kills for me but like you know what i mean like what's the point what's the point of adopting all these orphans so they don't fight for me oh
she has to be as hallucinating
oh he does not sound good right now where the is robin where are all my robins where is where is like red hood dark wing and all that I'm angry.
But I think Batman may be here.
If you see him, kill him.
Alright.
I thought I'd say what I have, like, a bonus.
I thought I could, like, destroy it for, like, bonus trophies.
Are they coming later?
Okay, because I'm like, what's the point of adopting all these orphans and letting them live in my house if I can't use them?
Where am I supposed to go?
I'm here.
right okay wait what does my detective uh this cover should be smashed open with if hit hard enough
ac motor twilight i wonder
no oh there's a door who would have thought there was just a door lying there in trophy location.
Oh, there's the Riddler shit.
Alright, goodbye.
How the fuck do I get this?
Scan in to add them to...
Oh, to add them to the map.
Oh, I see it.
I just hold it.
Okay.
Understand now.
Can I hold it enough?
Okay.
Alright, I already did it.
I don't have it yet.
Yeah, it's a point of exploring children for labor if they can't even do the labor.
If anyone asks about Mr. J, tell him he's fine.
No, don't tell him anything.
Well, tell him that you're not gonna talk about it.
And then shut him in the face.
Okay.
Oh, that's some good advice, Harley.
I think Batman may be here.
If you see him, kill him.
I'm not scanning.
I'm pretty sure I did.
Oh, I did not scan it.
Oh, it's not like I'm going to come back anyway.
Who are we fooling?
You think I'm really going to backtrack that?
I need to find a different way to get past Joker's men.
Are you splitting orange?
Oh.
The whole world will have forgotten about her boyfriend soon enough.
Then I get a ride on the heart.
And not...
Oh.
Whoops.
But where did it come from?
We'll never know.
Alright, drop down to take them out silently.
Okay.
He doesn't know.
Shhh, good night.
Hello, boys.
Who are you waiting for?
Nice, we did it.
Oh, I should have dived through the window.
I like the little oar walk that I do.
Wait, there's something over here.
I'm going to prevent access.
How do I access it, though?
Let's see.
I feel like I don't have any of these things that they want me to do.
Yeah, I don't.
Oh, yeah, I can't do it now.
Yeah, I was thinking, like, can I even do that now?
We make our own doors.
That's so dumb.
I like how they were like, oh, no, the door is locked.
What will we do?
Tell him he's fine.
No, don't tell him anything.
Well, tell him that you're not going to tell him about it.
She repeats.
Oh, it seemed like the new ones would say something new, but I guess not.
Wait, there's something up top.
What's this?
Uh.
My logo.
Oh, my God.
For God, he fucking draws his logo.
You do not need to draw.
logo a circle is fine Batman I am an artist I was gonna say what the fuck am I drawing a logo it says branding he
has to let them who's they I'm the only one you doing it?
I'm the only one that can see it.
Who the fuck is day?
I want to know if I had to go anywhere here.
I'm definitely going to forget all these controls when we do part two.
Chat, I can already feel it.
Hello.
I can do a silent takedown on this guy.
Oh.
Alright, nice.
I can do a double takedown on these guys.
Is that
all of them?
Oh wait.
I can go here.
And then drop attack!
And then away I go!
He's here!
Don't let him get in!
Drop attack!
And away I go!
Oh shit!
Drop attack!
And away I go!
He's like, where did he go?
Oh, please, please.
You gotta keep together.
Oh, but what if I...
Okay, maybe...
Yeah, I am, though.
You all wear nice little dresses.
Wait, what if I could just do this?
That's right.
Yoink.
Um, yum, yum.
Get over and fight up.
There's someone stuck up here.
Get over here.
That's right.
Yeah, get over here.
Oh, wait.
How did he know?
Drop attack.
Oh, shit.
He's shocking.
He has a gun.
Drop attack.
Oh, my God.
He has a gun.
Oh, thank God.
Time to die.
I got it.
Okay, I got the...
Smoke bomb!
Pocket sand!
Oh no, not the fucking bullets.
Don't worry, yeah, he doesn't know.
You smoke to get away.
He doesn't know.
Fucking stupid.
Wee!
Stop letting him do that.
I really...
I gotta stop letting him do that They don't know They don't know Guys, how are you alive?
Okay, we'll go over here I'm 1 HP right now Guys, maybe I should have got the fucking unarmed shit
How the fuck was I supposed I'm supposed to know!
I don't one-shot!
Alright, I gotta watch this.
He's gotta go underneath me.
And then I'm...
You look scared, boy.
I don't blame you.
Okay, that's not fair.
What's going on?
I thought we were in charge.
Okay.
This was the only one.
way and then these the and now there's only one oh shit it wasn't one it wasn't one it wasn't one who would have thought and now there was only one okay get up You know, I don't know...
There we go.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah, now there's only one.
It was a miscount.
We did it, guys.
Whoops.
Don't worry, I got you.
Okay, that doesn't work.
I thought it would cut it.
Can you stand?
Give me a second.
What's wrong with these people?
That crazy woman thinks I can fix the Joker.
what's wrong with that what's wrong with it some kind of toxin oh it's the yeah he blames something called Titan Titan yeah do you know what he's talking about he kept going on about his last laugh isn't that information supposed to be confidential happening how does she know what we're saying get that door sealed up nice and tight boys oh shit I gotta believe they won't be getting in they have guns what do you mean we're safe wait here doctor i do not feel safe what the hell are you doing i need to get out of here someone needs to stop joker oh my god is that a gun you'll be safe you sure what the you hear anyone coming hide i'll be back
Remote electrical charge.
Non-lethal.
That's good to know that's non-lethal, Batman.
Alright.
Don't worry, it's non-lethal.
Okay.
I assume I have to use it for this.
Where's the gun?
Oh, there we go.
I should head back to the loading bay.
It's the only route to Joker.
The loading bay.
Oh, I have to just go this way.
Oh, hey.
Why does this do?
Oh, does this push it?
Oh, that pushes it.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I shoot the Harley bots now.
Oh, oh my god.
I need to get back after Joker.
Alright.
Oh, is that for the trophy?
I didn't even notice it.
Not gonna lie.
Okay, then...
Can we go this way?
Okay, I have to go backtrack.
this i actually have to go backtrack this this was just a trophy room here we go this way and then where is it there you go it's the only route to joker all right oops i do it what did i do Hello?
Hello?
Oh, okay, RB.
I don't even know when it's RB and when it's RT.
Or is this trial and error?
Oh my god.
Why are they all so stupid?
Why do I activate that?
Why?
You're chicken.
Well, you two just shut the hell up and get ready.
I don't like this any more than you do.
But if we got one now.
Look out!
That bitch!
Okay.
That's...
Wait, does that kill?
Does that kill?
Or is it just a stun?
It said non-lethal, guys.
Wait.
Now do that with what?
Wait, what does that do?
I'm just curious.
It said non-lethal.
Oh, shit, he threw it.
Oh, is it just a stun?
Aw, that's unlucky.
It was...
I'm just thinking, that would be pretty funny.
They said non-lethal, so I was testing it out.
How lethal it was.
Okay.
Just get him out of here, then.
It's just a little taser.
How the fuck do I get this shit going?
Ah, I have to use the batter and...
Is there anything?
Alright, there you go.
Okay, oh my gosh, all the way back here.
Oh, wait, there's one here.
Oh, wait, not the explosives, Joe.
Wait, is that not?
Oh.
That wasn't it.
I thought there was one over here.
Okay.
All right, this way.
Wasn't there like...
Yeah, I was like, remember there was one here.
No!
I didn't think she would talk!
She would stop talking!
Not...
I was not supposed to I should stop talking.
There we go.
I scared her away!
I was trying to zap her.
Did I do it again?
Oh, there's more.
Where does this go?
I have to dislodge.
Yeah, I'm going to say that.
I feel like I dislodge it.
There we go.
I'm just wanted to see him Oh shit Hammer hammer meet Mr. Hammer Oh my god Oh he has one arm Yeah Alright let's get these guys out of here though oh my god that's what he's gonna do apparently holy shit bro oh my god bro hammer bro was scary hammer
holy shit oh my god combo bro i'm doing nothing to him i'm actually i'm doing Wait, nothing!
Okay.
It's just nothing.
There's no place to find you.
And bait the living crap out of you.
Alright, there we go.
Thank god.
Okay, now I did something.
That's crazy.
It's like just a flesh.
spoon all right what's my next upgrade chat i learned this in jojo it's hammer time all right there's i don't think there's anything i could upgrade here but i have special combat bat swarm special combo boost uh back claw i feel like maybe i should get back claw disarm but i don't is that actually a good upgrade or is that just like it's like uh cosmetic
This time?
Alright, we'll grab that.
So I'm gonna use that.
Oh, oh no, it's term- it's stigma and it's terminal.
Wait, he's actually dead.
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait, it is terminal.
Out of my way, Quinn.
Leave us- just leave me with him.
I said blue.
Bro, what the fuck that, man?
Oh, you found him be- Oh!
Surprise!
You fell for the old fake Joker gang, Batman!
Satter up!
He's alive!
For how many fuck- Get jokered?
The detective will be busy with the Joker for a while.
Good.
For how many body doubles does he have?
so what next help tall brooding and handsome or help myself do all the loot professor strange has locked up in that vault of his i know difficult choice you're hitting batman with a batman find croc and have him rip a hole into the vault ask penguin for some explosives not my style i always prefer a woman's touch in these situations stay where you are ivy i'm coming to get Wait,
Poison Ivy?
She's here?
Oh my god!
I need to get my kit for my apartment.
Okay.
Alright, I guess I'll go back to my apartment.
Never mind.
I thought we're gonna have some exciting catfight.
It's a girl's day.
But Tanya's Pamela was transformed by a science spirit gone wrong into a planned human hybrid.
No, that's hard.
end poison ivy there they were they are roommates eco-terrorism often puts them in a conflict with batman whose iron will usually protect him from her seductive powers there is iron will began horny thoughts be gone i will not be tempted by you seductress since her counter dark night on arkham island ivy has been transferred to to Arkham City.
Taking refuge in a vine-covered stronghold, Ivy would rather keep you mad anyway than participate in a Ganwar.
Alright, I'm going to use a bathroom real quick before we do this.
I'll be back.
This place is falling apart.
There's no food.
Everyone hates each other.
Strange just keeps talking.
If I ever get the chance to get close to Strange, I'm taking the pick down.
...
I'm back.
What does Mr. Strange say?
Any special treatment?
No special treatment?
That's fucked up.
Let me double check some stuff.
Thank you for the super chat.
Oh shit.
I can't see all of it.
Alan, bike, medium, Minna, Ma, Zechra.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
I gotta find my fucking apartment apparently.
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's my whip.
Whatcha.
That's cool.
I like that.
Oh my god, look at me, girl.
I might not be able to glide, but look at my fucking whip.
Oh my god, I'm actually like a cat.
It's like I'm catwoman or some shit.
Yeah, I live here.
God, red at Gotham City must be so fucking cheap.
Isn't like metropolis like sort of like next door to Gotham City?
Or is that just from the Harley Quinn show?
I was supposed to find out where she lives anyway.
Two-face said she lives somewhere near here.
Where is my house?
Like here?
I don't question the boss.
You shouldn't either.
I know, I know.
But I'll get me so pissed all of a sudden anyway.
Oh my god!
Hoocha!
That's right.
It doesn't stop, boys.
It should have been me.
That's why it never stops.
I don't think this kills.
I think this just stuns.
Why are they still alive?
live okay yeah i'm fucking get out of here yeah it definitely does not kill i'm pretty sure that took get down oh oh shit wait he has a gun let's go meow do it until morale increases Damn cat woman.
Alright.
Thieves' vision.
Oh, look.
There's my cat.
It's good to be home.
Enough crack whips.
It's Johnny Test time.
This is a Johnny Test episode.
Calatrops.
An entire personnel device used to lead traps for unsuspecting enemies.
Anyone walking over there will be tripped up and fell out to the ground.
Alright.
Oh, well, that's...
It's to knock down enemies.
Oh, is that my Batterans?
Time to find Ivy.
Pounds when under mesh ceiling.
Holy shit.
Okay, that's not even anything related.
That's just being a spider, man.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
In case you haven't seen it, I wanted to let you know that was going through a tough time this week.
Your stream mesh to make me smile.
Thanks, Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I'm glad you've been feeling a lot better from the streams.
I really appreciate that.
I hope you feel better, man.
All right, open.
I'm just like, I'm like cat spotter now.
Half spotter, half cat, 100% woman.
Watcha.
It's Johnny test time.
Wee!
Like, nah, I've seen a cat.
Like, if a cat is fucking climbing up the grates like that, I would, like, I would call a scientist.
Like, this is a fucking scientific discovery right there.
Bye.
Yeah, that's me.
That's me.
I'm cat woman.
Like, we got a fucking fire.
We gotta like...
We gotta breed that cat to make...
Oh shit, cats can't swim!
Alright.
To make more of these spotted cats.
What do we have here?
Weird out of place plants, check.
Mindless hypnotized henchmen, check.
The oh so subtle odor of rotting pumpkins, check.
Looks like...
And she smells like pumpkins?
...to Ivy's lair.
Alright.
Oh, Jesus.
Oh, my God.
Let me just...
Give me a sec.
I'm trying.
Oh, my God.
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to use my whip right now.
It's not working.
All right.
You can watch.
You can watch if you want.
God, I wish that were me.
Yeah, I go this way.
Hold and swing down.
Oh, Jesus Christ, it's so dumb.
I'm sorry, it's so stupid.
Like, her fucking cat spot and shit.
Not here?
How do I get in?
huh is it oh maybe it is something related to this and I just start crawling from the goddamn grates like a spider cat yeah I fucking knew it okay there's a trophy though hey
girl ready for girls night out you here shouldn't have come here I'm not I thought we I thought we tight like that you're not seriously going to hold better against me forever, are you?
You killed them all.
They were just flowers, Ivy.
I'll buy you some new ones.
I know a place that...
Whoa!
Rumi?
Come on, Red.
What did she make?
Oh, for the love of...
Oh, she made, like...
Mindless boyfriend zombies.
Don't worry, they don't have a...
Good.
Pachah.
Just give me a...
Oh shit!
He's like, do not be tempted by her!
I got you, bro!
Don't worry, bro!
I got you!
Bro's before hose!
Yeah, the tempress is among us.
There you go.
Alright, we got to go.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
Oh my god, they're like just waiting in their little cocoons for me.
Can I like kill the...
Okay, yeah, I was gonna say, can I like...
Do you really think you can beat Mother Nature?
I'm a cat.
I'll just pee on it.
Isn't like cat pee like super toxic to plants?
Or was that dogs?
I know like apparently like dog poop and pee is like super toxic to plants and shit.
Freak.
In this.
Watch out.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
It's like, I got you, bro.
I got you.
Don't let her tempt you.
Bros.
before us.
Are we done yet, Ivy?
I just want to talk.
That's all.
If you're still breathing, it's not over.
She's consistent.
I'll give her that.
A billion microorganisms will enter your bloodstream.
Okay, but we already have microplastics from what we learned today.
Is it really...
Oh, wait, what?
When I'm done, your flesh will be replaced with butter.
What is this combo?
Oh my god, wait, I have like a double...
Oh, shit, Ivy.
I mean, the cat woman.
That's fast.
Wait, where do I go?
Oh, there she is.
I just need your help.
Never.
Not again.
Look, I can get you Harley.
You've got some nerve, Selena.
Oh, I don't like this.
Wait, I've seen this situation before.
Oh,
you're right.
I forgot because I'm Catwoman.
Oh, wait, it's too late.
No one's who you think they are, my dear.
Why spoil the fun?
I've seen this in Japanese before.
There's nothing wrong with you.
Nice of you to say, but you of all people should do.
there's plenty oh take my blood for example i wish somebody would this stuff is killing me why should i wait is this blood transfusion there's a teeny little bit of me and you too oh my god he fucking gave me his blood that is fucked up don't tell me it's not what you always wanted look bro he's inside me time I need your help I nearly had a cure it was so close and then it was taken this is like my toxic galley both die I'm fine with that are you imagine sucking down that last breath knowing that Gotham is doing the same oh so he gave him his blood so he'll have to find a cure I've spent weeks shipping samples of my blood to emergency rooms oh that's why the doctor I'm going crazy!
That's so fucked up!
Yes, he's a universal blood donor.
Never heard of it.
Hold tight.
That's so fucked!
Jesus!
The live chock-joker reaction.
Is someone feeling a little down?
What do you want?
Oh, that's just...
You're up!
You won't kill you.
Where is the cure?
Who has it?
I had our cold-hearted friend, Mr. Freeze, making it.
But he's gonna talk on me.
I'll find him.
I bet you...
Oh.
That's a little rude, Batman.
Alfred, Joker's poisoned me.
He may have poisoned Gotham, too.
Mr. Freeze has the only cure.
he zinged him if only it was that simple he'll be somewhere cold he needs to be kept at sub-zero temperatures to survive i don't wish to worry you i feel like he shouldn't be able to be outside heat signatures i'll find the coldest point in arkham city all right mr freeze i also forgot what he looks like i guess dr victor fries wait his last name is
freeze it's german i i know he's like european but i don't remember which what europe what part of europe victor freeze was a brilliant cryogenesis whose beloved wife nora was uh was stricken with fatal degenerate disease he placed her in suspended animation while obsessively searching for a way a cure for corporation that uh uh which europe i meant like you know which earth is it you know uh training acid accident that transformed fry his body into a blood cold blood form that will always be kept below zero at normal room temperature heat will die wielding a number of freezing weapons he and he wears protective armor his quest to somehow bring back his lovely wife All right.
Nora, no!
Okay, we gotta find...
We gotta find a colder place.
Just like here.
Oh, this way.
Give me a sec, guys.
I'm poisoned right now.
Gotta find the coldest point.
Freeze's lab must be this way.
I'm definitely heading toward the coldest point.
Wee!
Well, I can't believe I didn't think of this earlier.
A hotline straight to my nest as
far as...
Well, he asked my number now.
I think our relationship is really...
Whoa.
Damn.
Damn Joker.
A distress flare on this rooftop.
Either someone inside needs my help, or it's a trap.
What is this, Quest?
Oh my god, touch.
Stop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, that's...
Hmm.
But it's not the coldest point, though.
That's the thing.
Freeze must be using one of the old forensic labs.
I've got to get in there.
Look, I can save him.
Next time.
This is not as important.
So what now?
You two keep trying to get in.
I'll blow their faces off it.
Where's there?
Oops.
I leave.
Did I?
Oh shit.
Wait, what?
Oh shit!
Wee!
How did you miss?
Smoke pellet!
But first, let me kill you.
There you go.
What the fuck is it?
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Where did all of them come from?
Trying to find the coldest point here, bro.
Where the hell did he go?
That's a good question.
Yoink.
Is it below me?
Alright, let me kill these guys.
guys first.
Never mind.
They're, like, way too far from me.
They're trying to break in here?
Oh, I guess, like, here.
Wait, oh my god, there's so many dead bodies.
Batarum, batarum, batarum, batarum, batarum, batarum, batarum, batarum, batarum, batarum.
There seems to be a camera malfunction in sector 3.
Yep.
Camera malfunction.
Yeah.
There we go.
Got in.
I did not get in.
Wait, how do I disarm them?
Okay.
There we go.
No more guns for you.
Wait, how did he get his guns back?
I said no more guns for you.
Oh my god, please don't shoot me while I do this.
there we go Jesus Christ how did he get worse they could just do that pick up another gun that's illegal oh my gene crashed oh well I guess that's the game telling me it's time to stop guys
my game actually crashed well I'm too scared to come back to the game and see where I'm at so will that future doki handle this it hardly gets a watch from the chair no anything in the super chat thank you thank you I'm actually scared to see like to see where it takes me so we'll just let future toky figure out where i'm at during that level anyway guys yeah batman just dies and then like i guess the game's over he actually just fucking dies uh but i had a lot of fun that was really i've been i i'm enjoying the first part of uh batman arkham city i think the story so as someone who really likes dc um the story has has been so far very interesting um like i was not i was not aware of him that like joker fucking i guess it's like yeah the next the next aids epidemic like joker actually starting aids too was pretty fucked up i did not realize that um that was part of the story like that that's insane but that's actually insane of him to do um Yeah,
oh, yeah, seriously, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That was fun.
Thanks for tonight, Tokyo.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But thank you, everyone, for coming.
I always love streaming.
I always love playing video games, but I mean, yeah, I mean, sorry.
I always love streaming for you guys.
So it's been fun.
It's been a great first part.
I definitely won't do a longer stream for a part two.
I just been a little eepy today.
So I decided to not really do this morning stream as well.
So I was like, I gotta relax a little.
For those who don't know, we might have to change the game tomorrow because apparently the game Severance isn't out yet for tomorrow because there was an error on Steam or some shit for this game that they had to re-upload the game on Steam and then they don't check,
they don't like, they don't check the game, the checks i guess on the weekend so it might not be released tomorrow so we we're trying to figure out what game to play for tomorrow as like a backup uh but yeah just letting you guys know that like we might have to change the game because most likely won't be released by tomorrow um anyway guys uh as always everybody stay hydrated posh check get up and move around to get that blood pumping pumping get up everywhere get that blood pumping and if you stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody uh bye guys bye